you both appear determined to have your
script lovers and their right mind your
project yes made into a movie when did
you go from the mindset of writers to
producers like what what did you feel
that at some point you could pitch it
and someone else would make it and then
you started to realize okay if this is
going to get made well it was kind of a
interesting when we first developed the
outline for the project
it did have a production it was it was
for production her book was under option
yes she was under right so they were
open to writers to they'd sent the book
out apparently to a few writers to see
if they might have a take on it and I'm
not sure that they got a great response
but Janice had said can I try and they
said sure and I think that that what
this particular company was probably
looking for was a little bit of you know
love actual actually with like
multiracial couples because if you've
read the book it's kind of a how-to
guide it's kind of like so what to
Expect When You're Expecting the Steve
Harvey book had just come out I can't I
something yeah I can't remember it was a
dating book that was made with Amar's no
no no why can't I think about it because
Anika was in the second one but it made
two films and and so I think they were
looking for something more ensemble and
maybe a little broader and a little bit
more broader and a lot more comedic I am
I tend to be someone who gravitates
towards independent films I'm a huge fan
of drama and so my idea was more along
the lines even though this was a little
comedic but what you know like my Big
Fat Greek Wedding where it was one
couple that was dealing with the the
integrate intercultural dynamic and you
know guess who's coming to dinner was
also a big you know like when I was
thinking of films in the genre it always
dealt with one
you know one couple and their
relationship with their family so they
thought it was a really cool idea but
they didn't feel like they could sell it
and in the interim
novena Gabon and I had been dating and
he as an actor he was on homeland and
played Abu Nazir for two seasons and he
said well I want to see it because
you've been talking to me about this
project and you know and you know like
his big thing was in my research for
this or what it was like what's what's
really going on between us and so so he
barrington and I once the production
company he said well you know thanks but
no thanks I shed a few tears and then he
said well I want to see what you've done
what you guys have done and we met at a
Cooper cafe in Beverly Hills I will
never forget this and we were all ready
to kind of just like well you know we'll
hear you out but we're kind of done
because we didn't have the protection of
a production company behind us and we
left there I remember us walking to our
cars because he had come and then left
and we left after him and we were like
wait did he just talk us into writing
this screenplay and producing it
ourselves because he really felt like
there was something there he's like we
can do this movie this is you know we
can produce it ourselves and we were
just like wait did we just agree to do
this so we became de facto producers
because we wanted to see this project
done so yeah yes and and I don't think
that we've given up yet on the idea that
somebody might come in and sweep us off
our feet I know it's harder I mean you
get caught you you I think especially
early in the writing process you're like
oh maybe we'll just have the script and
somebody's gonna buy it they're gonna
make it and like we can go on with our
lives but you know you get attached to
some
and then you start to have more ideas
about how you might like to have it made
or you know how you you kind of want to
you you feel more ownership over it and
at this point it would have it would
have to be the right I think it would
have to be the right offer or the right
deal
fortunately I can as as my represents my
representation and and others nobody
seems to be jumping on the opportunity
to do it instead of us so we're probably
hopefully we don't we probably won't
have to make that choice I'll have to
bring on a real really yeah
producer it's more experienced producer
who knows people with money
yeah well Janice aside from you loving
drama and independent film why tackle
this subject dramatically instead of
using humor which seems to be the way
that people find certain things that
scare because a general huge drama queen
what want to do with humor um because I
think you can say so I mean I don't
think that this is completely you know
there's humor we always we climb back
and forth on whether to call it a
dramedy or a you know straight ahead
quirky Indies kind of fall in that
tonally in that I don't know uncanny
valley of is it a comedy is it a drama
and I mean we certainly have comedic
there's can see many elements it's just
not broad it's not a yeah it's not a
broad comedy and I think that it to me
you know it's an independent film in
that it lives in that same kind of
sensibility where you can have a film
feel like your life my life is not
completely dramatic it's not completely
humorous it just is my life and it
encompasses all of those things and so
this film encompasses that you know it
has some drama it has some comedy it has
some romance it has some sex you know
you know it has some life and so I think
that for me it's important
it's important for me for this film to
look like it's lived like it's it's it's
it's a project that lives in in this
time in this space it's really important
for me that the cast looks like the
people were writing about it's important
for me for them to sound like the people
that were writing about and so whether
that be you know a lot of the the script
has persian dialogue in it a lot of this
group has because Persian Americans do
speak their own language when they're
with themselves that's real to me and
that became very even in conversation
they can flow from Persian to English
and that's a part of the script because
and and and so a lot of my eavesdropping
and listening and having friends who are
at Persian and and having a Persian
producer and people involved with this
project who speak to the sensibilities
that we're trying to affect it gives the
film its life and so that you know
that's that's that's what that's what
connects me to independent film because
these are stories that that aren't
highly you know financed so you're
getting to the core you know we're you
know we finally found that like we've
got to cut some scenes because we can't
afford to like go to all these different
sets and so you get to the core of it
you get to the heart of it and not that
the the big-budget films aren't great
but there's something connective to me
about that kind of stripping down of all
the stuff and the glamour and the cutesy
and the whatever and you get to the core
of the story that's that's kind of what
I wanted to do is just tell them it's a
good story it's it's it drama comedy
it's a good story and I think that
what what's resonating with the people
that read it
you